you do not want to mess with these guys
they fight for a living and they're in
Qatar for super slam to the biggest
event by one of the Middle East's only
wrestling promotions Qatar Pro Wrestling
a host of legends performed at the show
none bigger than Rob Van Dam who's been
a main eventer for the biggest companies
across the globe it's very nice to be
able to come to places all over the
world where people grew up watching you
you've been you've affected their
culture in a way and sometimes you never
get to go to those places ever qpw has
been running since 2013 they've only had
a few events so fast the fans haven't
had many chances to the actual either
centering
very often but the company has big plans
they want to stage events like super
slam multiple times the earth and
they're aiming to start regular TV shows
the Qatar based Enterprise has also
opened up an Academy to groom local
talent
some of who performed that this very
show the vision we have is behind and
after World Cup 2022 and further until
2030 we become a contributor you know
asset to this market and the region but
becoming regional force won't be easy
the Middle East is a key market for the
industry's biggest name World Wrestling
Entertainment which is backed by
billionaire owner Vince McMahon it's
earning a reported 50 million dollars
per show the staged events in Saudi
Arabia till 2027 the WWE has also
expressed an interest in launching a
Middle East specific brand one of the
greatest minds in wrestling thinks Qatar
Pro Wrestling shouldn't feel too daunted
Eric Bischoff has managed some of WWE's
biggest rivals Rusli fans tend to be
very loyal
if qpw can continue to service the local
what I mean by local is Middle East and
established themselves as a hometown
team so to speak
I think that's an advantage that can
work in their favor and they can be very
competitive there are plenty of hard
knocks to head for qpw for now however
they're putting smiles on the faces of
people that Pro Wrestling needs the most
the fans Suhail malik al jazeera Lusail